what do you what do you think let's go
back to the abortion thing what do you
think about the history of planned
parenthood are you all familiar with it
the history of it no i'm not familiar
margaret sanger was i know the name but
i'm not familiar with all the
eugenicists and one of her uh we can't
say the name of the project she created
because it uses an iteration of the
n-word which would get us in trouble on
youtube but her idea was to go around to
the black community and start
propagating birth control practices to
stop black people from having kids let
me tell you something my mother was a
victim of that
okay there was a big scandal back in the
50s where doctors were systematically
giving women hysterectomies
right in order to to cut down the black
population that's right my mother was a
victim of that and you don't find that
out until you know 20 40 years later
just like the tuskegee experiment just
like agent orange you know the
government doing all these kinds of
things and you don't find out about it
until much later
yeah or like a fizer data dumps and
stuff like that they wanted to wait 75
years to give that information out but i
digress uh i'm into repairing the system
too reparation whatever you call
repairing it and i agree i don't think
throwing money at people is the way to
repair right the communication i mean
obviously communication is real do you
think school choice is legit or you
follow that at all school choice yeah
it's instead of like people sending
their kids to a public school every year
that costs a certain amount of money
instead you get a voucher for that
amount of money that you can spend at
any school of your choice or
homeschooling if you set up a
homeschooling curriculum
uh does that appeal to you at all
uh i'd have to i'd have to look at that
sometimes also it's very vague and i
don't know if i described it exactly
right but it's the idea that instead of
being um having to adhere to a public
school system or private that you would
get to choose what you where you send
your kid and you'll you'll have credits
along with that because i think
education and communication is the key
to moving forward absolutely 100 i'm i'm
100 pro education
and you know
it would have to be schools
that uh you know that are top-notch you
know you would have the right to go to
those schools i mean there was a time
where i couldn't go to harvard where i
couldn't go to princeton because because
of the color of my skin that's why we
have what we call hbcus right
historically black colleges and
universities that's why the united negro
college fund was founded and things like
that um so
and by the way i went to an hbcu i went
to howard university uh which was
founded by general george howard who was
a white guy
is that going to do it
so uh i'm trying to pull up the specific
story
google's not to uh
let me let me see if we can do this i i
did have another thing pulled up i want
to ask you about sure i i hope that
youtube can start to understand context
language well i mean we'll see if they
can if the algorithm detects the word
that daryl just said and demonetized the
video
that is just so unacceptable no it's
okay it's okay you use use the n word
which so you look like n n word oh let
me let me ask you uh
we have a story from independent harvard
university will hold first ever black
only graduation ceremony on this is from
may 2017.
do you agree with
institutions creating racially
segregated no
so i i agree with that and this is this
is not coming from the right this is
coming from like i said nobody has a
monopoly on stupidity let me i wanted to
ask you about the abortion thing because
it's big in the news and this is a
really fascinating one because one of
the things we hear from a lot of people
on the pro-life side is that
the foundation of planned parenthood was
eugenic eugenicists who wanted to
depopulate the black you know population
community in this country i just pulled
up the uh
1990-2006 it's a census government
abortion demographic and the interesting
thing is that in 2006 for every 1 000
women there were 14 abortions but for
every 1 000 black women there were 50
abortions
so
i look at this and i think is that
tribalism or that racism i think it's
racism both probably absolutely i think
racist tribes i think when you look at
the locations of planned parenthood
facilities they tend to be in black and
latino areas not lower income areas just
like um when you look at all the
advertisements and billboards um for
cigarette smoking and and alcohol
usually in uh impoverished black areas
yep
so i i'm curious as to what you you know
what your thoughts on this would be you
know why is it that
in 2006
for for every one thousand uh black
women there's 50 abortions but every one
for for every one thousand white women
there's 14 abortions how do you think
something like that happens
racism
racism sure but like
is it
are there racists who are advocating for
you know are these pro-choice racists
who are trying to trick black people or
how is it racist
they're trying to cut okay
let me tell you what's happening here
when when you were a kid even though
you're a lot younger than i am and when
i was a kid
when you even when your parents were
kids
and your grandparents were kids
the black population
in this country was 12 percent
native americans one percent
hispanic people around two percent
uh asian people around three percent
whites 86 87 percent all right
the u.s census is taken every decade
every 10 years you can google us
census.gov and see the trends all right
today
black people remain just over 12 like
12.9 13
all right native americans remain at one
percent
um
asians have pretty much doubled they're
like at five point nine almost six
percent
latino hispanic people have more than
quadrupled seventeen something percent
if you if you take
just
black people 12 percent hispanic people
17
that right there is 29 percent non-white
that's almost a third all right this is
happening all right
uh today the the last census was was
last year i'm sorry two years ago 2020.
all right white people in this country
right now are 59
all right in the year 2042
which is two uh decades from now
this will happen for the first time in
our country this country will be 50
white 50 non-white all right for the
first time
between 2045 and 2050 it's gonna flip
and whites will become the minority in
this country whites are already the
minority globally but in this country
they are the majority uh you guys may
may know the term white flight yep okay
white flight barely exists in our
country anymore because ameri the the
color of america's landscape has changed
so much
that anywhere you go there's already
somebody there who doesn't look like you
and so
people are people there's a large swath
of the america of the white american
population that doesn't care about this
happening hey it's evolution i don't
care no big deal i don't have a problem
with that but there's also a large swath
that does care about that they feel
they're getting squished out you know
you know we built this country we wrote
the constitution you know and now you
know our our identity is being you know
squashed out with race mixing and people
moving us out and so forth and so on so
they they are fearing this happening
and this is a problem for them
and this is why you know we're seeing a
lot of these things you know that you're
talking about voting rights changing um
and people you know uh i'm sorry good
just what voting rights in particular
where they're trying to rewrite the
voting rights bill and what's going to
be next the civil rights bill right i
just ask because
they're doing it everywhere and it's the
left and the right so i'm not sure the
context right so in in a bunch of the
blue areas they've they've changed the
voting laws dramatically pennsylvania
there was a lawsuit where they ruled the
republicans and democrats made an
agreement on voting changes that was
ruled unconstitutional recently so you
you you we're saying when you when you
have sat on the throne of power
for 400 years
as white supremacy has sat there it's
hard to get off that throne okay say as
you know some of us are musicians here
right so
if you have a number one hit
number one on the charts you don't want
to see yourself fall down the number two
and number three number four and then
fall off the top 100 you want to stay at
the top so when you when you sat on the
throne of power for 400 years
and i came here 400 years ago in 1619
all right
and you know you you got you got a our
our last president
sat on the throne of power for only four
years
and he thinks he's still there
it's hard to give up power
but i i
you're operating under the pretext that
like what a lot of what we're seeing in
modern politics from republicans is due
to them not wanting to lose white power
yes
but where where does that actually i'm
not saying just republicans
you know you know there are racist
republicans and there are plenty of
racist democrats okay do you do you
agree with um harvard's affirmative
action plans
what are they so if i believe in
affirmative education i believe
everybody i don't believe in lowering
standards in order to in order to having
quotas to get people you know up there
and lower the standard no i don't
believe in that at all but i do believe
in affirmative education giving
everybody an equal opportunity to get
educated so harvard it's uh if you're
asian you have to score i think 1300 and
if you're black or hispanic you have to
score lower like eight or 900 on your
sats or something like that so they make
it more difficult for asians they make
it easier for black and latinos i think
that's wrong i i think they should i
just said that yeah yeah don't look
don't lower the bar so this is the bar
up this is this is the issue i'm
fighting when i say things like critical
race theory should not be allowed in
curriculum
but now let's talk about what you just
said okay so i i i've sat there with
neo-nazis and kkk people etc and i said
how can you hate me you don't even know
me
and sitting two feet in front of me well
mr davis you have to understand one
thing you know you know black you know
black people are prone to crime
and this is evidenced by the fact that
there are more black people in prison
than white people
what he's saying is 100 true
the data shows that
the stat the statistics show there are
more black people in prison than white
people so what he is saying is 100 right
but so that justifies
his thinking you know
we need to keep black people down
because they will the crime will grow
but
because it enforces what he already
believes as a kkk person or a neo-nazi
or whatever
uh a white supremacist if you just want
to use a general umbrella
um
he is satisfied with that with that
statistic or that data he doesn't bother
to look behind the data and find out why
and why is it oh why is it because
uh black people tend to get imprisoned
for longer sentences than white people
committing the same crime when you find
a state like let's just say the state of
maryland a few years ago well more than
10 years ago governor paris glenn
denning of the state of maryland put a
moratorium on the death penalty
as as have a lot of states why because
black people were being legally executed
for their crimes where white people went
to prison for life or life with parole
okay so so so what he wanted to do was
you know we want to put a tenure
moratorium on the death penalty to study
why this is happening what the hell do
you need to study you know why it's
happening it's called racism white
people have been studying black people
for 400 years if you haven't learned
anything in 400 years you're not going
to learn anything in 10 years i think i
think class plays a a a big role in why
we see the crime rates the way they are
i think people who are in poverty
uh you tend to see higher crime in lower
income areas it's not absolute it's not
the only reason right but the the issue
with um black people in prison typically
what you'll hear from the right is i
shouldn't say the right typically you'll
hear from what identitarians is that
they commit a disproportionate amount of
crimes relative to other races
we hear that all the time but
why they don't have the opportunities
they're not being given the
opportunities why because of racism now
but that would be that that would be by
class
no no you know it's it's by the fact
it's by color okay it's by color i know
both
well it may be class but you know
as a black man i i have experienced
things that you guys will never
experience
okay
you know i get pulled over 10 times more
than you do all right huh do you i do
yes i do how do you know how many times
i've been pulled over i don't know but
but
by looking at you i can tell you i have
i have okay i reject that on this on out
right well then well then let let's
let's go let's go and compare those
times okay
and plus i've lived longer than you have
you have and you were around
to be fair considering you were around
in in pre-civil rights
absolutely i've been pulled over just
for having a white woman in my car
i know other people i've been uh i've
been pulled over and had cops playing
drugs in my car i've i've been pulled
over completely illegally like for no
reason at all and then had my license
suspended how many times so i've been
pulled over illegally in my life
probably four or five times
that's a drop of pepper and assault
shaker how many times you've been pulled
over you can't even count the number
like well i i was saying yeah absolutely
absolutely so and still today you are
you you are almost twice as old as i am
you were uh you've lived through eras of
you know pre-civil rights and all that
stuff so i i can't speak to that
but uh
i i've i've been pulled over and and i'm
not trying to say that uh i do
what i'm trying to say is i don't i
don't respect you telling me you know
outright without actually listening to
me or knowing anything about my family
or my life or what we went through that
you know outright i didn't experience
these things no no i didn't say you
didn't experience these things or that
no i said i've been pulled over more
times than you have is what i said
and and i stand you are older than me
though doesn't matter i mean
i'm i'm also a lot darker than you are
yeah oh yeah absolutely okay and i and i
had okay listen
i
i i lived in a place called potomac
maryland
okay which tradition is is an all-white
or predominantly white uh area it's it's
mixed now all right my family was a
second black family to move into our
neighborhood
my father was a senior
foreign service officer my father was
richard nixon's interpreter when he was
vice president of the united states when
he went to russia
he was vice president to dwight
eisenhower he went to russia to have
what's called the kitchen debate with a
nikita khrushchev the famous kitchen
debate my father was nixon's interpreter
my father was one of the first black
americans to speak russian all right
fluently my father spoke nine languages
fluently all right my father was one of
the first black secret service agents in
this country all right and then he and
the secret service would only let him go
but so high he did such a good job
interpreting russian for nixon nixon
came back and told eisenhower about him
and nixon and eisenhower called my dad
into the white house and eisenhower told
my dad you have gone as far as you can
go in the secret service you should you
should take the foreign service exam you
can go higher there so my dad took the
foreign service exam and became a
foreign service officer but there was
still a ceiling for black people in the
foreign service but but let me just
finish okay so in potomac maryland
my dad had a mercedes
second black family in the area my dad
was getting pulled over in our own
neighborhood i was a teenager what okay
when was it
we were there uh in 1971
through um
see i still own the house there but um i
i have another house where i live um
1971 he died in 2018. so
between the uh more black people started
moving in probably in the mid to late
eighties all right
uh they the cops thought my father
walked into the neighborhood and drove
out
so when i turned 16 i got what all black
parents give their young boys it's
called the talk
you have you heard of the talk i had the
talk too okay tell me about it okay the
talk the talk is what black parents give
uh six uh their their young boys
especially uh when they start driving
you know when you get pulled over by the
police even if if the cop is wrong do
not argue with them just take the ticket
sign it we'll go to court we'll we'll
sell it in court because you can get
shot but see this is the issue i have
with
i think what you're saying is racist
the idea that black people exclusively
do that or it's predominant among black
people when that's actually a normal
thing most people do no so perhaps the
class issue because my all of my friends
and myself had the exact same talk in
the exact same way i was told no matter
what happens when you're pulled over you
turn the light on you turn the car off
keys and wallet on the dashboard hands
on the steering wheel you roll down the
window and you don't move you answer the
officer's questions you do not argue
with him do you understand yes
say it back to me i'm sorry tim but you
were 100 percent wrong so but so
it's it's just no i i think it's fair to
say that you're older than i am you've
we we agree on the racism of the past
and i
absolutely well i completely we can
agree on the racism of the past but we
can also talk about the racism of today
and i agree
a lot on it what i don't agree with is
that
this you know uh this it's it's strange
to me to hear the idea of the talk
perhaps white suburban upper class wasps
don't do that but growing up in in the
south side of chicago in mixed race
areas and gang territory from chicago
and you're from midway
i'm from chicago 500 east 33rd right on
the south side right yeah midway so i'm
on uh 47th 49th and laramie so i'm two
blocks away from the leclaire courts
i had to talk to my friends all had the
talk everyone had the talk the talk
existed among white kids polish kids
mexican kids asian kids and black thanks
for checking out this segment from the
tim cast irl podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
monday through friday at 8pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com and become a member
your membership helps sustain this
company keep our journalists employed
makes this show happen and you will get
access to exclusive members only
segments of the tim cast irl podcast and
there's a massive library to check out
so again go to timcast.com or tune in
monday through friday at 8pm we'll see
you all there
you